GOOD MORNING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SECOND SO CALLED ORDER
-- PREVIOUS VISORS AUDIO
VIDEO RECORDED PLEASE PER
SEASON WE MAY AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED A MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
RAMOS RIVAS WICKS
YEAH YEAH YEAH
WE HAVE A QUORUM CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION SENATE CHEN
MOVE BY MS WORK SECONDED BY
MISTER GRAYSON AMEND SECTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
I CARILLO AYE FLORA GRAYSON
CREATION I CAN MODERATE OKAY
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS QUIRK
SILVA FIRST OF ALL I RAMOS
RAMOS I RIVAS RIVAS AYE
WORKS HI WICKS I'D MUCH
PROCESS CLOSEST FRIENDS
AND THIS POST WAS INJURED